- I'm trying to pace myself consciously,
because I know if I don't think
about it I will inhale this.
(upbeat jazz)
- [Woman On The Left] So today
we're in Koreatown, Los Angeles.
- [Man] And we're at Cafe Bora.
- [Woman on the Right] We're going
to try some purple treats.
- Bora means purple in Korean.
- Yeah, it's the purple cafe, literally.
What could be purple that's food?
- Because it's sweet potato.
- I love sweet potato.
- I love sweet potato too,
but I didn't know it was purple.
- Sweet potato's purple.
- No, it's like orange.
- There's different ones.
- Ah.
- Clearly we know a
lot about this subject.
- Yeah
(upbeat jazz)
This is the prettiest food
I think I'll ever consume.
- This is so fancy.
- I feel really cool.
- Oh, yo.
This is a building.
- There is some more purple stuff in here.
- [Man] I think this is the extra.
- Extra sauce, like I
always get on my Thai food.
(laughter)
Okay.
Oh, it tastes like
sweet potato, literally!
- It does taste like sweet potato.
- That's so crazy.
- In the best way.
- That's crazy.
- It's funny because I never
thought of sweet potato
as a flavor for shaved ice,
and it works so perfectly.
- Like, you can taste the sweet potato.
It's definitely the star of the show.
It's really light,
but the flavor's very apparent,
and it's really soft and
blends together really well.
- It tastes healthy, too.
It tastes like sweet potato.
- I think it's healthy.
I'm going to say it's healthy.
- It may be healthy by your standards.
(upbeat jazz)
- [Woman On The Left] It's so pretty.
Look at this.
- [Woman On The Right] It's so cute.
- [Woman On The Left] So soft again.
- [Woman On The Right] It's so satisfying.
- It's like a food porn, like.
Oh I love it.
- This is really good.
- It's a deep taste.
It's very deep.
- It's like full of flavors.
- The first thing you taste is
definitely the sweet potato,
and then you kind of taste like
a cream flavor right after.
- Yeah.
- It's definitely the
perfect soft serve texture.
It feels really simple
in like it's flavors,
but that's what makes
it really really good.
- The way when you spoon it,
it just goes in like that.
It's crazy.
- [Man] That's a solid scoop there.
- I know it sounds weird,
but there's something arousing about it.
(laughter)
- Whelp.
- You know what I mean though?
- I'ma leave you alone
with your food there.
- Oh, there it is!
- You said moist last time.
- This is moist.
It's moist.
- We got that on camera.
(upbeat jazz)
- [Man] Oh, it's very soft.
- Yeah.
- It's very arousing.
(laughter)
There's cake inside.
- [Woman On The Left] Super creamy.
- Oh, yeah.
That is great tiramisu.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Oh dang.
It's definitely a different flavor
than your average tiramisu.
- Yeah, I actually like
this better I think.
Less intense and less sugary.
- The sweet potato is a
little bit less pronounced
I think than the other two things we had.
- It's almost like vanilla.
- It's delicate.
It's like a few layers
of different flavors.
There's like the creamy layer,
and then you've got like
the more sweet potato layer,
and then at the very bottom
is like a yellow cake.
- Okay, sweet potato.
- As predicted,
it definitely came through aesthetically,
but also the flavor was warranted.
It wasn't just purple things to be purple.
- [Woman On The Left] Yeah.
- Like, you could really tell the reason
it was purple is because
it was sweet potato.
- Yeah.
- Very very aesthetic.
This is probably the most
aesthetic desserts I've ever had.
Everything's a fresh take for me here.
- It was a surprise.
It was very different than anything
I've ever tasted, but super good.
- Signing off.
- Peace.
(upbeat jazz)
(swoosh)